[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من الفنان السوريين وعربيين بارز
يتبوا موقعه في الصف الاول من نخبه
الفنانين العرب الى مهاجرين يعملوا في
خدمه توصيل البيتزا والورود وسائق في شركه
اوبر هذا مختصر ما تعرض له الفنان السوري
المعروف جهاد عبده الرجل الذي ان حاز ساعه
الانحياز لكرامته ورغبته بالحريه ولشعبه
يوم ثار في وجه الظلم والطغيان لم يكن ذمه
ما ينبئ بالسياسه في مسيره عبده طوال
مشواره الفني فنان ناجح ويتقدم في عمله مع
الصعود الكبير الذي شهدته الدراما السوريه
مطلع التسعينيات الميلاديه من القرن
الماضي يومها لم يكن من نافذه تطل منها
السياسه اصلا في تلك البلاد وكان قد درس
الهندسه المدنيه اول الامر قبل ان يتحول
لدراسه المسرح بعد ما اكتشفه في نفسه من
موهبه وحب للتمثيل والجهاد الذي ولد مطلع
الستنيات ودرس في رومانيا ابان الحقبه
الاشتراكيه
والتحق بيركب الفنون والتمثيل بعد عودته
لسوريا لم يكن يتخيل يوما ان مصيرا مثل
هذا بانتظاره لكن ورغم المحطات الصعبه
التي مر بها بعد خروجه من سوريا يوم اعلن
موقفه المؤيد للثوره والرافض للنظام
والظلم والطغيان والضراره بالهروب الى
الولايات المتحده تاركا خلفه كل شيء مما
جعله يعمل في كل المهن حتى يستطيع العيش
رغم كل ذلك لم تتوقف في عروقه مسيره الفن
والعشق الذي افنى حياته من اجله فكانت
هوليود بانتظاره وبعد عده محاولات بعضها
بالفشل والاخر بظهور بسيط لا يليق بقيمه
الرجل الفنيه وجد فيه المخرج العالمي
هيرزون الفنان الملاعب لاداء دور المشاركه
في دور المحوريه مع الفنانه العالميه
نيكول كدمه في فيلم ملكه الصحراء وشكلت
هذه المحطه عوده الفنان الى في الحقيقي
والمناسب لتاريخه وامكانياته جهاد عبده او
جاي عبده الاسم الفني الجديد له في ميادين
هوليود ضيف المقابله في هذه الحلقه فاهلا
ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
متى بدات علاقتك
علاقتي بالفن طبعا
لم يسلط عليها الضوء نهائيا
بعدين حصلت على منحه لدراسه الهندسه
المدنيه في رومانيا في رومانيا
فذهبت لدراسه الهندسه وكنا نحنا مجموعه
الطلبه السوريين كنا نقدم الثقافه
الهويه تبعنا الفنيه على خشبه المسرح
كطلبه
كل جنسيه كان السوريين اللبنانيين
الجزائريين
اليونان العرب نعم
فبما اني انا اعزف عليه
تعال تعزف معنا الى ما هنالك وشاركت ببعض
السكتشات المسرحيه
انتبهوا لي زملائي الرومان
طبعا العرب حبوا شغلي كذا بس زملائي
الرومان وكان في استاذ حكالي انت لازم
تترك الهندسه
وترجع على بلدك تدرس المسرح
وهذا كان نقطه انعطاء في حياتي
اربع سنوات في المعهد العالي للفنون
مسرحيه
للامام خطوتين الى الوراء خطوه الى الامام
يعني كان في شخصيات يعني مثلا بعطيك مثال
كان عندنا مخرج الله يرحمه فواز السعر
مجموعه اخرى من الاساتذه كان انسان عبقري
جاد عنده مشروع مسرح مهم بس للاسف يعني
اي نشاط فني اذا ما في دعم مادي
لا يزدهر بعدين بدات اعمال المسلسلات
ونهايه رجل شجاع الي ظهرت فيها بدور بارز
نعم وهذا وايضا بدايه نهضه الدراما
السوريه من جديد هي بدايه المحطات
الفضائيه الفضائيه
نحن بدنا اعمال بدنا اعمال فصار في دعم
مالي لهي الشركات الانتاج
وطبعا الكتاب والمخرجين من كل انحاء سوريا
في سوريا خاصه نهايه مرحله حافظ الاسد
بدايه مرحله بشار الاسد كان في نوع من
التحول تماس اللي كان يحدث مع السياسه
هلا
الوسط الفني بشكل عام بسوريا
كان الى حد كبير يدعي
انه هو
تقدمي ااه محب للتغيير للتطوير ثورجي لا
يقبل بالواقع
نضال موضوع النضال موضوع التحرر
بس نحن عمليا بالوسط الفني كنا منقسمين
ضنيا بدون ما حدا يقول الى موالي للحكم او
للسلطه
ولكن ليس من فريق
تمام وفي ناس ارتبطت بشخصيات بالنظام وفي
ناس مرتب في فنانين لم ترتبط انت كنت بعيد
عن النظام انا كنت بعيد كان عندك نقد
للحاله السياسيه
اما تحيد او بتفوت مشاكل وجاءت لحظه الحزم
امام هذا الاختبار الكبير اللي حال الفنيه
السوريه مع الثوره السوريه
من اول لحظه نحنا عبرنا عن راينا بكل
صراحه
وحكينا موقفنا بكل وضوح انه
كان القمع كبير جدا كانت الامتيازات من
الوضع انها ستنتهي تماما حتى بشير الفنيه
وهذا ما حدث معك
ما كنت متوقع انا لهالدرجه يعني هلا في
كثير ناس بالثوره ما كانوا متوقعين هذه
النتائج
الاطفال ما كانوا متوقعين شو راح يصير
معهم للناس اللي طلعت بالشوارع ما كانت
متوقعه شو راح يصير معها في كثير ناس ما
نعرفانين ولا منهم
عليك ان تتخذ هذا الموقف هو موقف اخلاقي
بحث انا من طفولتي من نعومه اظافري انا
ابن الريف
ااا من نعومه اظافري انا ما بحب مظاهر
الغنى
والبهرجه بحب انا اتعاطف مع الفقير مع
الانسان المظلوم مع الانسان اللي ماله صوت
قبل ما اكون فنان ومشهور كنت حاول اني
ساعد الناس اللي محتاجه ما اعرف كيف
ولذلك لما فت على الوسط الفني واكتشفت انه
نحنا بهذا الدراما بهذه المسلسلات نحنا
بنحكي وجع الانسان الفقير نحن بنحكي
بالتاريخ بالنضال حبيت هذا المشاعر بس لما
جينا على ارض الواقع وشفت انه هذا الشيخ
غير لا يطبق
رجعت واخذت موقف مع الشعب مع الناس بغض
النظر عن النتائج اليوم بعد مسيره من
الاوجاع والنظام والتعب والنجاحات لاحقا
تشعر لو ان هذا الموقف عدم مره اخرى تتخذ
نفس الموقف قريب منه ام لا نفس الموقف
قريب منه ولكن لن اكون ابدا مع اي ظالم لن
اقف مع الظلم من اجل الحفاظ على المكاسب
وما حققته لانه ما يمكن ان يحققه الانسان
هون
فليذهب الى الجحيم ممكن تحققه في مكان
ثاني
مجددا عندنا حكي كثير حول المسيره الفنيه
والمسيره السياسيه النضاليه ايضا والمسيره
العالميه يعني قصه فنان واجهه بعد نجوميته
ووجهها صعاب استثنائيه
سائق تاكسي
محل مطاعم بيتزا بيتزا بورود تصوير ورود
المرحله الصعبه
ولكنها انتجت ايضا يعني صعبه وممتعه في
نفس الوقت سعيد جدا بوجودك
الجمهور العربي والجمهور السوري على وجه
التحديد يسعد بموقف ونظام جهاد عبده الذي
يعبر عنه بشكل ممتاز شكرا
[موسيقى]
الله وكيلك يا ابي مو ناقصنا الا شويه
كرامه بس
هذا واحد من اهم المشاهد الدراميه في
تاريخ الفنان السوري دريد لحام في كاسك يا
وطن التي تعتبر من اشهر المسرحيات
الكوميديه العربيه الناقله بنهايه
سبعينيات القرن الماضي تحدث لحام بلسان كل
مواطن عربي تواق للحريه والمساواه
والعداله الاجتماعيه بعد اكثر من ثلاثه
عقود على ذلك المشهد المؤثر الذي دغدغ
عواطف الشعوب العربيه من المحيط الى
الخليج اندلعت شراره الثوره السوريه في
تلك اللحظه الفارقه والمفصليه والتاريخيه
لم يعتني لحام خشبه المسرح ولم يقدم مشهد
دميا واحدا يدين فيه قتل اطفال درعا
وتقطيع اوصالهم على يد الاجهزه والقوات
الامنيه
سكوت الرجل في ذلك الحين عن سفك الدماء
ومن ثم اعلانه دعما النظام السوري في سحق
معارضيه لم يكن في واقع الامر وترجمه
عمليه لسقف الدراما العربيه الذي يعلو او
ينخفض بحسب رغبه الحاكم ما خلق قله
القليله من الفنانين والممثلين الذين
دفعوا ثمن باهضا تاره بالاقصاء وتاره
بالملاحقه والاعتقال وحتى تصفيه الجسديه
بسبب مسانده المطالب المشروعه مائه غالبيه
نجوم الدراما السوريه بنفسه نفسها عن
الظلم والقمع والمجازر في مشهد راى كثيرون
انه يختصر الممثل الكبير الذي غالبا ما
يكون انسان صغيرا يناصر الاستبداد وينادي
بحريه الراي والتعبير من خلف الشاشه او
على خشبه المسرح فقط
بدك ياني ندافع عن الحبوس اللي صارت اكثر
من المدارس في شيء سجين ما لقوا له سجن
نام فيه بس في 1000 طفل الملحوحين
بالشوارع بلا مدارس يا مختار
[تصفيق]
الجهاز صعبا ما الذي كان ينتظرك هنا في في
امريكا
بصراحه انا ما كنت اعرف اني انا رح استقر
بامريكا جيت لهون لحتى انتظر لحتى تهدا
الامور في بلدي
وما عرفت يعني ما ما ما توقعت شو راح يصير
معي
لما اكتشفت انه ما في رجع على بلدي ما في
رجع على سوريا وكانت امور عم تدهور كل يوم
للاسواق تجاه الاسواق
ااا
واكتشفت انه انا راح ابقى مضطر في امريكا
اللي كان منتظرني هون انه يكون انسان وحيد
ما حدا بيعرفه
رقم مجرد رقم من هذا الارقام يبدا من
الصفر يبدا من الصفر تماما كل شيء عملته
وحققته وبعدين بكتشف انه مو بس انا يعني
حتى الاوروبيين اذا بنحكي عن الممثلين
الممثلين او حتى الاوروبيين اللي خلينا
نقول من لندن بيجوا على امريكا
كنت ما كنت بعرف انه انا راح ابدا بهذا
السلم من اول درجه
وانسف كل شيء عملته لمده 23 سنه وما عملته
في اوروبا سابقا برومانيا
وما كنت متوقع هذا الشيء خوفني كثير
اضيف الى ذلك الي كان عم ينتظرني هون هي
اني انا عم بسمع اخبار مؤلمه جدا كل يوم
عم توصلني من بلدي وما كنت عرفان انه هذا
الشيء راح يصير
ما كنت عارفاني اني راح افوت على بلد صحيح
امريكا بلد عظيمه بس كل شيء فيها مختلف عن
سوريا
السيستم الانترنت البحث التواصل
قيمك عن موضوع اللغه يعني اللغه ما كان
عائق كبير بالنسبه لي
اقمت بسرعه
غيري ما قدرت اقلام بسرعه بس
استل يعني موضوع
السيستم اللي قائم عليه الحضاره بامريكا
او التواصل او التعامل ان كان مع الحكومه
او بين الافراد شيء مختلف جدا واضطريت انه
يتعلموا على الكبار
بلدك وقع في همم يعني همم احوال واوضاع
صعبه
يعني كل تاريخك الفني مهم جدا عند جمهورك
العربي لكن هنا لا قيمه له يجب ان تبدا من
من جديد ما هو الخطوه الثانيه
قلت انا اذا بدي ارجع اشتغل بالتمثيل
بامريكا لازم
يعني اسلك الطريق الصحيح
اللي
يوصلني للمكان اللي انا بدي اياه شو هو
طريقته الطريق الصحيح انك تتعلم كيف
بيروحوا على الاوديشن كيف على المقابلات
كيف بيتواصلوا بين بعض كيف يقراوا ال ال
النص الامريكي ماذا تعني لغه الاشاره في
امريكا نحن تعودنا على لغه تعبير مختلفيفه
بالشرق الاوسط
مختلفه عن الهند مختلفه عن اوروبا مختلفه
عن امريكا اول درس حضرته بتعليم التمثيل
بيحكي لي المدرب ومساعدته كمان
لا تمثل احكي الكلام وكانه مجرد كلام
وكانك انت عم تدلي بهذا الكلام بدون تعبير
بدون تعبير بدون قراءه لا تعبر لا تنفعل
مع الكلام وهذا كان صعب علينا انا كان صعب
عليه انه ينتقل من حاله التعبير نحن اللي
بنستعملها نحنا بالشرح الاوسط له عم بحكي
لك انا المشكله من مجموعه من المشاكل
همم اول شيء سجلت ببعض المواقع اللي لها
السينما وحطيت فيها صور عني
المخرجين والمخرجين تصير سهله عليهم
حتى يبدا وكمان
تواصلت مع الطلاب العرب
بالجامعات صناعه بجامعات السينما في
امريكا
[موسيقى]
وبس يصير البيت جاهز بيعطوك اياه فاحنا
كنا مستثمرين بيت للجمعيات انا وزوجتي وكل
ما اشتغلنا بقرشين بنحطهم بهذه الجمعيه
لما اضطريت اني اغادر لا فكرت اني راح
ابيع هذه الجمعيات ولا فكرت اني رح ابره
فلما طولت وصار بيع هاي الامور هاي
الكليات الممتلكات صار المستحيل
انا بعتبر حالي خسرتهم كلياته ما بقارن
حالي بالناس اللي خسرت العزيز والحبيب
والزوج والابن والبنت بس انا خسرت كل
ممتلكاتي وما ضل معي مصاري ابدا
عرفت انه انا رح استمر هون بدي اعيش لازم
اطلع مصاري
شو هو الطريق بيدور على شغل
ما خليت محل ما قدمت عليه ستاربكس ميسي
اربع لغات
ومستعد اشتغل 24 ساعه يعني باي توقيت ممكن
توصيل بيتزا همم زهور زهور وبلاش توزع
زهور طبعا كانت صعبه جدا
كنت عم بسوق هالسياره كان معي تويوتا
كورولا
[ضحك]
المقعد الوراني معبا كلياتهم ورد وبوكيات
وكذا ووصلت على منطقه فتت فيها واذا انا
فايت على الداون تاون لوس انجلوس هل
بنايات الشاهقه ناطحات السحاب وبلشت اشاره
تبع الموبايل تروح الجي بي اس بالبنايه
بالبنايه بروح
والوقت حرج لازم توصل هذا البوكيه اللي
مكتوب عليه هابي بيرث داي عيد ميلاد سعيد
اليوم المحبين
وقت حرج وانا ضعت وما اعرف يعني اتوه اطلع
من شارع وما قدرت اوصل وهذا المكان راح
يسكر لان هو مكتب ولازم نوصل هذا البوكيه
او هي قطعه الورد لصاحبه بالوقت المناسب
انا بتذكر لهلا لما ضاعت المره الثانيه
وتاهت الجي بي اس وقفت بنص الشارع وصارخ
وصرت ابكي عن جد
نزلت دموعي وقلت ليش يا رب ليش ليش عم
يصير معي هيك لحتى جاء شرطي دق عليه في
مشكله
هي وحده من المشاكل اللي صادفتني لانه لما
بيسافر الانسان بعمر كبير وما بيعرف
السيستم كثير صعب عليه انه كثير صعب عليه
انه يتعلم على كبار
نعم هذه الفتره استمريت حتى التقطت الفرصه
الفرصه مع
ضيف في المقابله في عام 2016 المخرج
الالماني العالمي الشهير في فيلم ملكه
الصحراء
كيف حصلت على هذه الفرصه وهي كانت المدخل
الممتاز لجهاد عبده كانت نافذه كبيره جدا
المخرج العظيم
شخص من بلاد الشام او بيتكلم اللغه
العربيه من بلاد الشام يعني سوريا فلسطين
لبنان الاردن
اللي يدور الفيلم عنها
الشخص هو من سوريا
[موسيقى]
بلاد الشام ويتكلم الانجليزيه البريطانيه
وليس الامريكي
فهو شاف عدد كبير من النجوم الامريكان
اللي من اصول عربيه او من اصول غير
العربيه
لم يجد فيهم ما يبحث عن
في صديق مشترك جمعنا فيه وقال له في ممثل
من بلاد الشام اسمه جهاد عبده شوفه وانا
ما كان عندي وما كان عندي مانجر كنت
بالبدايه وما عندك رصيد امريكي
لانه بيسالوا هذا شو اشتغل
المهم دبر لي لقاء مع فيرنر مع المخرج
وانا لحتى اقنعه بعد ما قرات الناس عرفت
انه هو هذا الشخص اللي اسمه فتوح بيلعب
دور
همم يعني الدليل دليل في الصحراء
وانا بعزف على اله الكمان وهو عازف
الربابه فهو يعزف الربابه
وساعدتني زوجتي انه لقتلي
قصيده نبطيه اظن او قديمه من باليه الشام
واعطتني اياها وطلبت من الصديق العزيز
مازن الناطور يساعدني باللهجه باللفظ
فارسلت له اياها
همم القصيده
السن البدالي لون سكر اليازيج
ثم اشتقى من عقب لا هو قبالي
استغفري يا بنت يا ام العشاشيج
عن قوله تتشليه من عبيد الموالي
حنا عبيد الرب سيد المخاليق
ومما بدا يا بنت هذه فعالي
لا لا لا لا لا انا ايضا عندنا
يس يس يس
ادركت من وقتها انه هو معجب كاني انا
اخذته لهذا العالم
حكيت له انهم بيسافروا على الجمل على ظهور
الجمال ليالي وجد ضالته فيك
وكانت هذه يعني دخله ممتازه لك لهذا
العالم مع مخرج عالمي مع نيكول كيدمان في
فيلم عالمي ملكه الصحراء الفيلم لم ينجح
تجاريا لكن فنيا لكنه فنيه
شل النقل اللي حصلت معك استاذ جهاد بعد
المشاركه طبعا انت حكيت لي عن معاناتك في
في مساله السفر وعدم وجود جواز لك واظهار
الجواز الابيض جواز اللاجئين نعم نعم يعني
كلها معاناه حقيقه التفاصيل
في الدول العربيه كان صعب جدا جدا لانه
معي
يعني بشق الانفس كنا نحصل على الفيزا
للاسف وهذا الشيء المفروض يتغير
حركه الانسان اي انسان بالعالم المفروض
تكون حركته سهله جدا يؤلمني جدا انه في
ناس بكثير دول من العالم
ولدت بهذه الدول وما عندها جنسيتها هذا
الشيء يؤلمني جدا وبتمنى انه يطور ويتغير
مع الوقت للافضل هوليود ما بعد ملكه
الصحراء كيف اصبحت بالنسبه لجهادته صارت
اسهل شويه
لقيت مانيجر كبير
صرت قدم على ادوار اكبر مع مخرجين واعمال
مهمه
شاهد الصدف اني انا العب بسته افلام قصيره
وصلت لسباق الاوسكار وهذا الشيء كمان سهم
انه يحط اسمي على الخريطه في هوليود ايضا
في دور القصير
الافلام ثلاثه
عن طريق الامم المتحده بياخذوها بياخذوا
العائله كلياتها على بلده صغيره بسويسرا
شمال زيوريخ فيها مشفى خاص امراض
السرطانيه المراه المتزوجه بتموت بعد
يومين
وهم الزوج انه يدفنها على الطريقه
الاسلاميه دليله
بقول له انا هدفي الوحيد امنيتي الوحيده
انه تطفر زوجته
عن نفسي تروح على الجنه
وهو تبدا المعاناه معاناه اللاجئ نفسه
ومعاناه الرجل السويسري اللي عم يساعده مع
المنظومه كليات الاوروبيه
والتي لا تقبل الانسان المختلف يعني لي
بابسط حقوقه هو انه يدفن زوجته على
الطريقه الان في المرحله الاولى انت فنان
فقد يعني بلده فقد رصيده الفني وجاء لبلاد
اخرى مثل امريكا يريد فرصه فيه خلود هذه
المرحله الاولى تمت هل تم مرحله اخرى
بمعنى ان يظهر الشهاده
يعبر عن فكره ما همم شيء ملائم بحيث ان
يكون له اسهام معين لقضيته سواء السوريه
او العربيه اي قضيه
نعم ولا الامر صعب ليس صعبا ابدا هو صعب
ولكن ليس مستحيل وانا استغليت فرصه
الكورونا لحتى ادرس كيف يكتب السيناريو
بالطريقه اللي
معتمده
الكبير فعملت جبت الكتب ودرست وحضرت
تدريبيه شفت فيديوهات على اليوتيوب في هذا
الخصوص التي حوالي سنه
وكتبت فيلمين فيلمين بيحكوا عن قضيتنا نحن
عن قضيه الانسان المعذب الذي اضطر ان يترك
بلده واحده كتبت قصه حياتي انا
لقيت مخرج ولا نحن بصدد الانتاج قصه
الانتاج وهي قصه انسانيه
يعني هلا ما بدي اقول لا علاقه لها
بالسياسه السياسه موجوده على مائده الطعام
السياسي في كل شيء خاصه في حياتنا عرب
خاصه في حياتنا كرم وكسوريين
وكتبت فيلم ثاني
له علاقه ب سوريا ورومانيا وامريكا حيث
تجمع البلدان او القارات الثلاثه موضوع
مشترك واحد الا وهو الهروب من البلد او
اللجوء الى بلد اخر ماذا اما شارك الفنيه
العربيه هل توقفت تماما لا يوجد فرصه
للاستمرار كفنان عربي بارز خاصه ان ان
الدراما السوريه والفن السوري كانوا كانوا
مزدهرا بشكل كبير جدا
لم تنقطع الفرص اجتني بعض الفرص لم تكن
يعني حسب مثل ما يعني بمستوى الطموح بس من
شهر انا رجعت من الاردن من عمان كنت همم
تصوير صورنا بمسلسل اسمه
هلا هذا هو العنوان همم
حضور لموكب الغياب
وبيحكي عن عن فلسطين وشرق الاردن في عام
1930 الانتداب البريطاني وبدايات
فلسطين نعم نعم احتلال فلسطين
وانا برايي انه راح نرجع للوطن العربي
باعمال مهمه ان شاء الله لانه دائما في
اعمال مهمه دائما في اعمال جديده اود من
خلالك استاذ جهاد واقيم موقف الفن
الفنانين وموقف الوسط الفني بشكل عام خاصه
في محطه مفصليه كانت الربيع العربي ثوره
الحدث في سوريا او في مصر او كذا يعني
يلحظ انه غالبيه المنتمين لهذا الوسط
كانوا ميالين
للموقف الرسمي مواقف الانظمه قله ولكن قله
مهمه اللي كان اتخذت مواقف مؤيده للشغل
كيف ترى موقف الوسط الفني السوري تحديدا
مما جرى في سوريا هلا نحن انا دائما كنت
تقولها هاي نحن كنا مفوزين
قبل
الثوره او قبل ما ينطلق الربيع العربي
نسبه كبيره من الفنانين بالعالم
لما بيصير في تغيير
وبهدد
الامبراطوريات اللي بنوها الفنان ابني
امبراطوريه مع الزمن اي انسان
مغير لموقف النظام او السلطه كل هذا بتهدد
لذلك انا بعرف انا كنت عايش في رومانيا
موافقه على سلوك النظام عشان هيك نحن
بنشوف احيانا تصريحات من هون ومن هون من
الناس مواليد
لانه البشر بطبيعتهم مليانين للحق للعداله
للمساواه
بس احيانا بنحاز وخوفا على فقدان مصالحهم
خوفا على فقدان هذه بس يا ترى انه انت
عندك القوه انك تبدي هذا على هذا يعني ولا
بتاكلوا اشكاليه عدم الانحياز فقط للثوره
كان محياز بفاجاجه للانظمه
والتحريض وما الى ذلك يعني احيانا كان في
شيء زائد حتى عن حاجه الخوف يعني يسمح
للانسان ان يصمت ربما ان لا يقوم بعمل لكن
التاجيج والتحرير والمهياز ربما لا تليق
بفنان ملتزم خصب من الفنانين كانوا يؤدون
اعمال تتحدث عن الحريه وعن الثوره وعن
الكرامه وعن مواجهه الاسترداد
نعم نعم هذا صحيح وما بعرف يعني في اسباب
عديده بتدفعهم لحتى
يحرضوا يعني لحتى ينحازوا لهذا او يروحوا
لهذا المستوى بس كل انسان عنده مبرراته
يعني انا ما بقدر افهم ما بقدر افهم هذا
الشيء
فنانين اتخذوا موقف يعني موقف جمال سليمان
في مجموعه من الفنانين السوريين المقابله
استاذ جمال استاذ عبد الحكيم لطيفه
الله يرحمها مجموعه كثير كبيره
غياب التمويل هو المشكله الاساسيه نحن
بحاجه الى محطات وراس اموال رؤوس اموال
تتبنى
اعمال جاده تحكي عن الم الناس يا اخي لا
تحكي عن السياسه اتركنا من السياسه تحكي
عن الم هذا الانسان اللي واقف
بدون شحاطه ما في شيء برجله واقف على
الثلج
لا تحكي بالسياسه يا اخي
بس ليش ما بتحكي عن هذا الطفل اللي هو
بالمخيم عم يموت من البرد
ان تظهر تظهر اسباب لماذا حدث هذا عمره
بالتالي
التغريبه الفلسطينيه عالجت بدميا يعني
تقريبا
سوريه اليوم
اكيد اكيد
اكيد في محاولات عم يعملوها الشباب في
اوروبا بس بصراحه نحن بحاجه اسمها القوي
لحتى نعمل عمل مهم
التغريبه السوريه
تغريبه يعني فعلا هي دخلت بالتاريخ وانا
عم بحكي لك انا بشهادات ناس ليس بسوريين
شهادات امريكان اوروبيين منظمات حقوقيه من
اهم المنظمات في العالم انه لم يحدث
اي شكل من اشكال الاستفاده من هذا العالم
الفني الكبير المذهل المؤثر
همم نحن اخذين فكره شوي مغلوطه عن هوليود
انه منحاز الى او ضد كذا مو صحيح هذا
الكلام اا هوليود فاتحه ابواب لكل الافكار
وكل همم مستويات يعني وانا عم بشتغل على
هذا المجال عضو نقابه الممثلين هنا
الامريكيين اصبحت مواطن الامريكيه وتعمل
في هذا المجال وتعرف الوكالات ايضا المهمه
المؤثره في في هوليود كيف ينظر للقضيه
السوريه وللحاله والمقاسات السوريه في هذه
الاوصاف هل تمت ارتباط الاحتكاك تعاطف ما
او عدم اهتمام في تعاطف الى حد كبير اا
همم في تعاطف خليني اقول لك الى حد كتير
كبير
في بعض الاصوات اللي بنسمعها اصوات يعني
سلبيه بس قليله جدا وتحارب ضمن هوليود وهي
محاربه يعني
همم
الان يعني في مجموعه من الاعمال
تعمل او تنجز عن سوريا تحديدا في مسلسلين
تلفزيونيه سوف يتم انجازا عن سوريا
مسلسلات
انا بعتبر انه هوليود قادره وجاهزه لحتى
تساوي اي شيء عن اي شعب عم يعاني في في
التاريخ يعني ما في مشكله من وين جايه بغض
النظر انا بحب كلمه بغض النظر التعاطف
الانسان بغض النظر
عن العراق
عن اي شيء
الحديث الدائم عن عن المعارضه السوريه وعن
النخب السوريه الموجوده في الخارج يعني
قطعا لابد من وجود بعض الامكانيات التي
يمكن ان تساهم في صناعه عمل كبير سينمائي
تعرف السينما رسالتها اكثر تاثيرا من كل
الادوات الاخرى فمن الغريب انه لم يحدث اي
حراك سياسي معارض سوري تجاه عمل ما او
اتجاه احداث اثر كبير او اختراق في صناعه
الراي العام المؤثر سواء في امريكا في
اوروبا
والاسماء البارزه بالمعارضه
والناس اللي بره
بس على ما يبدو نحنا كعوب ما عندنا ايمان
بقوه السينما هوليود
امريكا غازيت العالم به هوليود
اول ما بتقول لاي مواطن في اي مكان بين
انحاء العالم عن امريكا
[موسيقى]
بس نحن بحاجه لحتى نعرف هذا الشيء لحتى
نساوي ما الذي تغير فيك يا جهاد عبده بعد
ان اصبحت هوليودا كثير شغلات
كثير شغلات اول شيء
يعني بصراحه زادت ما عرفتي للعالم
صار الافق اوساع ااا زاد تقبولي للناس
ايقنت انه انا ممكن يكون بيوم من الايام
رقم لذلك
انكسرت هاي الشوكي وصرت انا انسان يعني
اقرب للناس مما كنت عليه
صار عندي حب للمعرفه اكثر
صار عندي حب للبحث البحث عن المعلومه
تغيرت علاقتي بزوجتي صرت افهم انه زوجته
هي الي وقفت معي وصنعت مني هذا الانسان
وخليتني يشعر بالامان همم هي بتستاهل
اهتمام اكبر مني وانه همم
بكل خطوه كانت معي الفيلم الوثائق الذي
يعد عنك من قبل الجزيره
شكرا همم بيقول لك يعني حتى نظرتي لزوجتي
وهي خل ساعدتني بانه تنعكس نظرتي للمراه
بشكل عام
وانا بالاساس كان عندي نظره
افضل عن المراه
ما عاد مهم جهاد عبده كاسم
مهم ماذا يقدم جهاد عبده ماذا سيترك وراء
جهاد عبده هذا المهم بالنسبه لي
الامور ما بعرف يعني بجوز ما بعرفها بس
كمان مثل ما قلت لك بحب المعرفه وحب
الاطلاق حدثت الثوره السوريه في 2018
مقالات الثوره السوريه اليوم اود ان اسمع
او استمع الى وجهه نظرك حول ما يجري في
سوريا
المخرج
[موسيقى]
هو ان نستمع لمطالب الناس
هو هو يعني كانت الرغبه الاساسيه انه
نستمع لمطالب الناس الناس ما بدها شيء
كثير بدي امان بدي ما حدا يعتدي عليها
ااه بدها تشعر بحريتها ولما بقول انا
الحريه هي الحريه في كل شيء حريه الاعتقاد
حريه التنقل حريه دراسه حريه الزواج
التعبير عن الراي حريه التفكير انا انا
التقيت
بالتقيت بالسوريين مقيمين بامريكا من 30
سنه
حسيت انه اخذين معهم شرطي صغير
جواتهم
شرطي شرطي لانه نحن رمينا على هذا الشرطي
فعم ناخده معنا وين رحنا وصار في نقاشات
انت في بلد الحريه
نحن هذا الشرطي لازم نعرف ان هم نزرعوا
فينا لما كنا صغار فلازم نتخلى عنه لازم
نكسر هذا الحجار هذا
الجدران اللي انبنت حوالينا حوالين
ادمغتنا وننطلق لحتى نصير احرار بالتفكير
حريه التفكير هي اسمن ما لدينا العقل هو
اثمن ما لدى البني ادم نحن هذا الشيء لذلك
بقول يعني انا اذا اذا بتصير في ترجع يعني
الحريه ببلده السوري بحس بحريه اليوم برجع
تعتقد انه هذا امر يمكن لنا ان نفكر فيه
في ظل همم الوضع الحالي في النظام الحالي
في النخبه السياسيه
النظام يعني النظام واصل لمرحله مغلقه
خلاص يعني لا طريق مسدود
وانا برايي دائما في مجال للتراجع
في مجال للتراجع وفي مجال لمنح الحريات
الحقيقيه اطلاق السجناء اطلاق اطلاق الناس
السماح للناس انها تحكيلي بدها اياه
ممكن ترجع على البلد ممكن يطرح سيناريو
اصعب او او يعني تفكيرا اكثر يعني اكثر
صعوبه بمعنى انه حدثت مجازر كثيره كان
هناك دماء هناك مقاسي كبرى وبالتالي كانه
في رغبه قويه جدا بالانتقام لا تعطي فرصه
تسويه او اي شكل من اشكال التسويه همم بين
الطرفين انت وين رايح وين تفكر منه انا
دائما بيرجع للمبادئ بيرجع للحريه اذا
توفرت الحريه
في جزء من هذا النظام سينهار سيزول وراح
يروح انا اللي بدي اياه بدي العنب لا بدي
اكل الناطور ولا بدي اتسلي ولا انا بدي
الخلاصه بدي هذا الشعب يرجع على بلده اذا
تحققت هذه الامور الاساسيه اللي هي الحريه
احساسهم بالحريه راح يرجعوا البلد تتعمر
ان شاء الله بعد 20 سنه
عشان هيك انا مستعد اقعد معه اي انسان
اقعد مع انسان كثير مختلف عني
واشتغلت معهم بنفس الاعمال
ناس مختلفين عني بالايديولوجيا بالفكر
بالدين الى ما هنالك
ضلينا نتواصل مع بعض لذلك انا مستعد اقعد
مع اي انسان سوري مهما كان يكون واحكي انا
واياه تلتقي بنخب سوريا
في امريكا او او خارج امريكا احيانا ما
الاثر الذي تركته هذه السنوات كلها من بعد
2011 على السوريين برايك انت فنان الاثار
اللي تركتها على السوريين خارج سوريا سواء
في تركيا في العالم العربي في اوروبا في
امريكا في احساس عام بالفقدان الامل في
احساس بانكسار
تصمي مئات الرسائل انا دائما توصلني رسائل
مؤلمه جدا جدا جدا
فقدان امل صعب جدا بس
برجع بقول
ما في شيء ثابت
مثل ما في حكومات ثابته كمان ما في طريق
مغلق الا ما نلاقي
منفذ بس اهم شيء اهم شيء واللي النظام هو
اللي زرعوا فينا انه يفرق تسود لا تخلي
حدا يحكي مع حدا نحن لا بدنا نحكي مع بعض
بدنا نتواصل مع بعض
توصيف الناس او تفسير الناس على انها
مساله طائفيه
لما بترجع بتحكي مع المختلف عنك ليش انا
بقول لازم نحكي مع بعض وتسمع وجهه نظره
وتسمع تقرب منه
بصير الحل ابسط بكثير
لا شك انه في ناس عززت عندها موضوع
الطائفي للاسف يعني من كل الاطراف من كل
الاطراف النظام اصلا بنيته كانت يعني واضح
انها عمل على الطائفيه بشكل لكن حتى في
المعارضه اصبح هناك جماعات والتشدده دينيه
تعتقد ان الامر 17
انما استغل في موضوع الطائفه لخدمه
المعارف وكليته اقتصاد وكليات بسيطه
كلياته مال وللاسف نحن لا انا لا يمكن
نفكر انه فلان من الناس عمل فيني هيك مشان
اختلاف طائفي وانما
للمكاسب والسيطره
على ماذا يعمل جهاد عبد الان من مشاريع
انا حاليا اعمل على فيلمين مثل ما قلت لك
ومسلسل تلفزيوني امريكي
في فيلم كمان عملناه فيلم قصير اسمه
اللاجئ او اللاجئه
عمله مخرج امريكي
راح يصير تصويره عندي كمان دور جميل
مقابلات مع مخرجين
الحركه المسار الحركه الفنيه السوريه
انتهت ولا ولا مازال فيه امل يعني ما
انتهيت وانما المواضيع التي تتطرق اليها
قد تكون تلوي عنق الحقيقه لانه لما بنكون
بمكان لا مجال فيه
كلمه الحريه فحتى التعبير الفني راح يكون
ماثور انما المواهب موجوده الكتاب موجودين
المخرجين موجودين نحن مثل ما قلت لك بحاجه
الى متنفس من الامل ومتنفس من الحريه فقط
هذه الصفحه من العذابات التي بدات ب201
الجامعه ويطلب منه ان يبدا من الصف الاول
الابتدائي مره اخرى هذه الصفحه انتهت ولا
ما زالت يعني مفتوحه باوجاعها وامامها
ههه
ما انتهت
احيانا
انا
بسوق اوبر لليوم
رغم اني انا مرتاح
بس في شيء من عامل في بعض الامور تدفعني
لاحيانا اركب بهالسياره وطلع معي واحد
واحكي معه
هذه الايام اللي تعبت فيها وما كنت لاقي
فيها اكل
وزوجتي واقفه بالشارع عم تشتغل كنت تبرعات
بعملها
وانا عم دور بها السياره ووزع بها الورد
ووزع بالبيتزا بحب ارجع اتذكر هذه
اللحظات القاسيه
وحاليا شفت لما بشوف اي انسان عم يشتغل
حواليه بحس قديش هو عم يتعب وقديشه انسان
محترم لحتى يوصل الشيء اللي بده اياه انا
شاكر جدا انه هذا الوقت وعلى مجيئك منه
نيويورك ايضا لاجراء هذه المقابله استاذ
جهاد سعيد جدا بهذه التجربه بنجاحاتها
الاولى كانوا فنان سوري
وبنحيازك يا ايضا الانسان البدائي
والاخلاقي لشعبك وللقضيه العادله وللثوره
السوريه وفي هذا النظام ايضا في السنوات
التي ذلك والنجاح الذي اعقبها هذا النظام
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا في هذه
الحلقه شكرا لك يا استاذ علي انا بيشرفني
اتواجد على هذه المحطه
وبنيك جدا على هذا البرنامج العظيم
الشكر موصول لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على طيب
المتابعه القاكم ان شاء الله الاسبوع
المقبل دمتم بخير وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]